let's wrap this up okay I got to get out
of here I got to drive all the way to
[ __ ] Irvine tonight I wasn't asked if
Tom could tell you about the curse of
little B he knows all about it yeah
thank you no more little B little B he
really did curse Kevin Durant right he
did Carson and it worked
Kevin was no no part of that Wow I mean
nothing apologize
no but Kevin switched teams because of
the curse who knows he said he was never
gonna win a championship ever again or
ever really I think that's what Lil B
said and then he took the curse off I
believe yeah I think you're right these
multiple people but it didn't he cursed
Hardin because because uh it didn't
credit ferment I believe his movement it
was like you know cooking like I got to
eat whatever is stirring food up I'm
eating right now like when you when
you're killing it right and like that
was a little B's move so nobody lifted
it looks like you lift it C lifts curse
and James Harden yeah it's Chris
multiple people on Twitter it's a thing
you don't want that's when what happened
I took that texted you as I go see what
the thing is when when a guy like that
says he's cursing you like that's what
voodoo is all about it gets in your head
that's right mind [ __ ] you what is he
dressed like yeah
did he really dress like that yes he
dressed like a chick with a like an old
lady's hat and a dress on he's
definitely a wide variety of outfits
fascinating yet fascinating he wants to
a podcast oh you should do it it's just
God yeah we're gonna come in the base
guys gonna come down here yep we're
gonna keep it poppin feet and face photo
send him in feet and face yeah that's
what he wants one of his themes yeah he
wants girls feet and their face I showed
me your face too how we got to show your
feet yeah cuz it can't be busted well
like yeah what if you have a nice
feeding your face is on wreck for the
other thing yeah or the other way around
yeah keep your socks on if you're hot
funky feet yeah that's right don't want
to see that [ __ ] he is a serious
character though yeah man he's an
interesting guy interesting guy he's
probably the first guy to come with the
public curse like who who else yeah
who's publicly curse people no no and
it's worked that's what's crazy it's
just it's bold just to have that in your
arsenal I'm saying of of insults or be
like to be the first like if somebody
was somebody said like Joe this dude was
talking [ __ ] about you and you're like
that's fine
I just curse that [ __ ] like that
in and of itself is just terrifying yeah
especially if it works
confident move man I want to say that
the bass God's curse is gone from Kevin
Durant okay Thunder are free now to win
future games you can't win hating like
how he signs all of us his tweets Lil B
yeah he signs and that's okay so he took
that off a while ago I didn't realize
that but I remember when it happened I
was like boo
it's not good